la culture en jeu d'égalité pour le
département les yvelines remettait hier
un chèque de 3000 euros aux équipes
pédagogiques du collège plaisir wa
blaise pascal
un montant qui se traduit par des cartes
lire pour le futur salon histoire de
lire de versailles nous savons tous que
il fallait l'origine famille l'origine
sociale des familles détermine souvent
les parcours des élèves
pas toujours mais c'est souvent le cas
bien entendu et on le sait depuis
nombreuses années les élèves ne vont pas
à paris par exemple ne vont pas à
versailles
si on va pas si nous n'avons pas des
projets à leur proposer n'y vont pas
donc eh bien voilà tous ces projets font
que nous pouvons les accompagner puisque
sans financement eh bien les collèges
serait fortement enfin fort démuni 160
millions d'euros sont consacrés aux
collèges publics et privés du
département comme dix neuf autres
établissements blaise pascal est inscrit
en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
nous souhaitons que les collectivités
aujourd'hui et tout le même je dirais
mais les mêmes apports positifs pour
pouvoir avancer
on a des collectivités qui sont mieux
dotés que d'autres on a des
collectivités plus en difficulté que
d'autres en tout cas on a aujourd'hui la
nécessité et le besoin d'abord cet
accompagnement la des départements et je
crois que département cherche à trouver
une capacité pour accompagner que ce
soit la ruralité que ce soit les villes
qui sont encore en transformation c'est
un canton dont les villes sont encore en
devenir
parce que elles ne sont pas stabilisés
elles sont pas stabilisés une ville
comme versailles est une ville achevée
on la retouche à la marge
plaisir c'est une ville qui se construit
encore plaisir à une originalité c'est
que il ya un quartier d'habitat social
qui est en plein centre ville ça
n'existe dans aucune autre ville des
igloos un quartier social qui s'est vu
doté d'une enveloppe de 65 millions
d'euros pour une rénovation en
profondeur les travaux valley beau
doivent commencer en début d'année 2020